vestimentairement parlant il ya eu deux
périodes dans ma vie celle où ma mère
m'a payé à croire que ma mère choisissez
mes vêtements comme ça mais c'est quoi
cette merde je me prends on peut
comprendre que j'ai envie d'arriver
assez rapidement à la période où je
choisissais mes vêtements
c'est entre le primaire et le collège et
là je me suis fait une petite folie à
j'avais un style assez incroyable
puisque j'avais des baskets un jean un
tee shirt voici normal man
j'adore complet et les films de quentin
tarantino norman le gamin le plus normal
du monde
d'ailleurs j'ai pas trop changé en fait
j'aimerais avoir un style un truc un peu
original et tout mais en fait non j'ai
peur que si je tente
j'ai cette réaction est salut les
copains ça va elle salue sipri qu'est ce
que c'est que ça c'est quoi j'ai pas dit
ça
nos portes je crois que c'est tombé sur
moi un moment j'avais pas remarqué mais
je suis assez admiratif des gens qui
arrivent à avoir leur propre style
j'avais un pote au lycée il est devenu
gothique
c'était pas mal le seul truc bizarre
c'est qu'il est devenu boutique du jour
au lendemain ça se trouve ça peut
arriver à tout le monde et que le type o
mat le type feu par exemple ça c'est
loïc attend une seconde
[Musique]
alors que le type insectes qui bat le
type psy c'est n'importe quoi c'est
comme le type dragons qui ballottine
dragons depuis dix ans
n'empêche c'est quand même important le
style vestimentaire sa détermination qui
tue et à quel groupe tu veut appartenir
abbas il ya des scènes que j'ai rarement
vu quoi que j'ai jamais vu hier soir
j'étais un vernissage comme je te disais
tu sais que mes parents possèdent
l'appartement et tu la galerie
d'exposition très bien tu obtiens un
débat mais bien un débat d'idées le
frère darwin comme pouvait plus t'as pas
une fois encore un fils à papa et ça moi
tu pas ça moi tu vois comme ça moi la
mode tout ça mais vraiment épatant comme
pour qu'un truc soit à la mode il faut
lui donner un nom tu as un truc moche tu
donnes un nom ça devient à la mode
attend mais ton pantalon il est trop
petit ah non mais bon quand on n'est pas
trop petit c'est un sim attassi safin a
bâti sa salive alors que ça va désolé je
pensais que c'était important de trop
petit mais non c'est à ce niveau sim à
temps mais ton pantalon est trop grand
il est pas trop grand mon pantalon
c'est un bailli assez vague ajoutant
pour moi c'est un pas qui ça va alors si
c'est un baggy ray c'est comme lui il a
aussi un baggy à longs mois par contre
ça un pantalon trop grand au porte à
porte un mot trop grand franchement
j'aime bien tous les styles
1 les gothiques les hipster les sportifs
les gens normaux mais il ya vraiment des
trucs que je ne peux pas cautionner je
peux pas attention à chaque fois que
vous retournez le col d'un polo ou d'une
chemise pour vous donner un côté cool un
chaton se suicide
c'était un message de la planète toute
entière yassa et ceux qui portent des
lunettes de soleil
la nuit ces mecs là j'ai envie de leur
dire pourquoi pourquoi tu porte des
lunettes de soleil alors qu'il n'ya pas
de soleil
je me suis aveugle ah oui et comme j'en
ai marre d'être norman j'ai créé mes
propres tee shirt je dessine tous les
visuels et c'est en édition limitée
c'est quoi déjà le site déjà ah oui
marmol point fr
[Musique]
comment plier un tee shirt en 3 secondes
enfin c'est le milieu de l'épaule ainsi
que le milieu de la ligne parallèle aux
tee-shirts rabaté l'épaule sur
l'extrémité retourner le tee shirt et
mettez le à plat retournez le une
deuxième fois
c'est bon vous êtes officiellement le
maître du monde